what's up everyone welcome to my channel
Richard on data if you're new here my
name is Richard and this is a channel
where we talk about all things data data
science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this and hit the notification bell
so YouTube notifies you whenever I
upload a video so in applied statistics
and in data science practice a lot of
what you do revolves around making
comparisons and examining associations
between variables
I actually just did a video on the
distinction between prediction and
inference and with inference you're
basically trying to say that some
variable X when you change it that
causes a change in some other variable Y
one super simple and popular method of
making comparisons between groups is the
two sample t-test so maybe you're
comparing two groups with respect to
their response to some drug C you run
the test then you find that it looks
like Group A is responding better to the
drug than group B is well today what I'm
gonna talk about is the most important
principle in statistics as far as
interpreting and making any kind of
comparison like that is concerned and
that principle is called Simpsons
paradox so here's the literal definition
of Simpsons paradox it basically says
that trends that appear when data are
separated into groups can disappear or
reverse themselves altogether when the
data are aggregated now I'm going to
restate that a different way because
this way is how most people in real life
end up tripping themselves up and making
wrong conclusions from data a trend that
appears in an aggregate data set can
completely reverse itself when you start
separating that data into multiple
groups to put this yet another way the
relationship that you observe between
two variables and let's just call them x
and y that relationship can completely
reverse itself when both of those
variables are influenced by some other
lurking or confounding variable let's
just call that one z to illustrate this
we're actually going to look at two
different examples of Simpsons paradox
so you're gonna see
exactly why this happens in the first
place and then the major implications
and takeaways too when you're doing
I wouldn't say just data science but any
kind of data analysis in general so this
is gonna be our first example and we're
looking at two different treatments for
kidney stones now kidney stones can be
small or they can be large I don't know
what the size cutoff there is but all I
know is I hope I never get one of any
size because from what I hear they sound
absolutely horrible but anyway overall
treatment B appears to be doing better
if you look down under the both stones
in the bottom row it was successful 83%
of the time but treatment a was only
successful 78% of the time but here's
what's going on if you look at where
these treatments were applied
notice that 263 cases out of 350 for
treatment a were applied to large stones
treatment B however 270 out of 350 times
was applied to smaller stones which are
easier and less complex procedures so
naturally both treatment rates are
better for small stones than they are
for large stones so because treatment a
is disproportionately used for the more
difficult large stone procedure it
appears to be worse overall despite
actually outperforming treatment B for
both groups so you saw an example there
with categorical data a treatment looks
like it's doing worse because it's
disproportionately used for harder cases
but once we start looking at it under a
microscope the effect totally reverses
now let's look at an example for
continuous data this is our second
example here and here we have on the
x-axis hours exercised in a week and on
the y-axis we have probability of
getting some kind of disease
unfortunately much as I envy their
position I'm not sure how to people here
exercised for a negative number of hours
so just bear with me on this one but
when we plot the scatter plot with a
line of best fit there's a moderate
positive correlation of 0.33
so as hours exercise goes up risk of
getting this disease also appears to go
up
so right away I like this because if
this is true that means I can go out and
I can cancel my gym membership right
well no now here's what happens when we
stratify all that data over age so we
have two groups here we've got an under
50 group and we have an over 50 group
now the correlation you saw earlier has
completely reversed it turns out age was
a lurking variable here and it turns out
that older people who are at higher risk
of getting the disease in the first
place
exercise 4 more hours than younger
people do hence causing the apparent
correlation that you saw earlier when in
reality both age groups as they exercise
more appeared to be at lower risk of the
disease so here's the takeaways when we
observe a relationship between two
variables x and y it's way too
instinctive and easy for us to assume X
causes a change in Y however that's only
one of multiple possibilities it could
be y causes a change in X it could be
the relationship you see between the
variables is completely due to random
chance alternatively what's often
happening is that there's some other
variable Z which is influencing both x
and y and in fact you saw that here size
of a kidney stone influenced the chance
of a treatment being successful age
influenced the chance of getting a
disease so you saw when we compare
groups that were disproportionate with
respect to some confounding variable we
came to wildly misleading conclusions so
here's the thing when you're comparing
groups or especially when you're making
any kind of statement about causality be
very careful because these problems are
much more complex than they can appear
on their face not only might you not
have causality which is something that
requires a large amount of domain
knowledge in order to know for sure
you might not even have
through correlation in the first place
you saw two examples here so you see it
doesn't matter if the data are
categorical or continuous you have to be
very diligent use your domain knowledge
and your relationship with your client
to rule out or at least control for any
potential confounding or lurking
variables before you make any definitive
statements about comparisons or
associations so thanks for watching this
video if you found it helpful smash the
like button also leave me a comment down
below and let me know instances where
you've run into Simpsons paradox
yourself until next time Richard on data